JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
HERE.
MORE LUCK.
MORRELL [inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
STERN STONE.
NUMBER.
WHY KASKI?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE RECOGNIZE
THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM --GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES MISTER THIS
ONE IS ON THIS LIST ONE OFTENI
FIT IT PERFECTLY BEFORE I GAVEL
DOWN.
THE PRESSURE OF YOU ALL BEING
HERE WATCHING ME.
AND BEING ON CAMERA MAKES ME
SCREW IT UP MR THIS ONE OFF AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO HEAR TWO
TRAILER BILLS.
AB ONE HUNDRED SAFE AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER AND AB ONE ALL --
THREE WHICH IS OUR HEALTH.
TRAILER BILL NUMBER.
TWO THESE BILLS ALONG WITH FIVE
OTHER BILLS THAT WE'VE HEARD
OVER HE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
WILL BE ELIGIBLE TO TAKE UP ON
THE FLOOR THIS AFTERNOON.
I WOULD NOTE THAT AB ONE OH ONE
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
TRAILER BILL -- WE WILL NOT BE
HEARING TODAY AND MAY BE BACK IN
COMMITTEE LATER THIS WEEK FOR
DISCUSSION.
MISTER VICE CHAIR IN THE
COMMENTS FOR ME BEFORE WE GET
STARTED OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL HERE AB ONE HUNDRED FINANCE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SO THE FIRST BILL BEFORE YOU AB --
ONE HUNDRED ESTABLISHES THE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FUND AND THE ADMINISTRATION IS
GRATEFUL FOR MANY THE
LEGISLATORS HERE FURTHER WE SHIP
I SEE SENATOR MINING HERE.
ON THE COMMITTEE SO THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH THE SEVEN FOUR
DOUBLE DRINKING WATER FIND --
UNDER THE PROGRAM ACCORDING TO
THE AGREEMENT THAT WE NEGOTIATED
WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATUREAND COMMITTEE STAFF --
IN THE BUDGET YEAR THERE WOULD
BE A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND AS WELL AS THIRTY
NINE DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR
THE THREE YEARS AFTER THAT THERE
WOULD BE A 5% CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
UP TO ONE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND THEN IN THE YEARS
AFTER THAT BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THROUGH
TWENTY THIRTY THERE WOULD BE A
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE DOLLARS
DEVOTED TO THE PROGRAM AND ITS
TOP WEREN'T COMPLETELY FILLED BY
THE 5% CONTINUES APPROPRIATION.
THERE WOULD BE ATTACK FELL FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO REACH THAT
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE DOLLARS
LEVEL.
I'M AS ALL OF YOU KNOW THERE
ABOUT ONE MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO DON'T HAVE
CONSISTENT ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER SO
THE WAY THIS TRAILER BILL
STRUCTURED IS TO MEET THAT GOAL --
PROVIDING WATER TO THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE AFFECTED THAT'S TRUE THE
CONSOLIDATION -- WATER SOURCES
IT'S THREE EXTENSION OF THOSE
WHAT CLEAN WATER SOURCES --
THROUGH A SET AT SUPPORT FOR
OPERATION AND WITH A REAL
FOCUSED ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE COMMITTEES WHO DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE WATER GET THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES --
SPECIFIC -- REPORTING LANGUAGE
FROM THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PUTTING TOGETHER
THE FUND IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AND
SO ON AN ANNUAL BASIS TO NOT
ONLY HAVE TO PUT TOGETHER THAT
PLAN.
REPORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE ON
HOW THEY'RE PUTTING IT TOGETHER
AND WHAT METRICS THAT WE'RE
MEETING A YEAR TO YEAR.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE MAIN
PROVISIONS AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS. SEVEN TO
NIELSEN.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THERE ARE NO
THEN TAX INCREASES IT AT ALL IN
HERE'S STRICTLY GENERAL FUND AND
GREENHOUSE GAS CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT THIS IS A MAJORITY VOTE
BILL. SEVEN TO WORK OWSKI ON THE
UNIVERSE -- ON PAGE. THIRTEEN OF
THE BILL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SMALL.
OUR STATE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
OUR SYSTEM SAID HAVE UP TO
FOURTEEN HOOKUPS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT OF THE
MILLION PEOPLE THAT YOU
REFERENCE ABOUT HALF OF THEM.
MEET THAT JURISDICTION AND THE
OTHER HALF ARE OUTSIDE THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES.
CONTROL BOARD IS THAT CORRECT.
A THIRD I GOT THE PART OF
FINANCE SO I'M NOT SURE THE
PACIFIC BREAK OUT BETWEEN THE
SMALLS AND THE LARGER COMMUTERS
AND WE COULD DEFINITELY PROVIDE
THAT -- INFORMATION AFTERWARDS.
SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IS
THESE GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS IF
THE STATE.
MORTARBOARD DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION OF WITH.
PEOPLE'S WELLS FOR PEOPLE THAT-HAVE SYSTEMS THAT ARE LESS THAN
FOURTEEN HOOK UPS.
WE'RE STILL POINT TO PROVIDE
THOSE PEOPLE WITH ASSISTANCE.
EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER THEM.
BASED ON THE LAW THE NEW
LANGUAGE I JUST SAW.
YES SO -- THIS LANGUAGE DOES
PROVIDE THE AUTHORITY FOR THE
WATER BOARD TO HAPPEN TO HELP
THOSE INDIVIDUALS INTO THE
VENTURE COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY
WHICH IS WHERE -- SOME OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUE LIES -- THEY DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE THAT REGULATORY
POWER OVER THEM A LOT OF THESE
COMMUNITIES DO SUFFER FROM NOT
HAVING -- SAFE DRINKING WATER SO
THIS FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOWABLE
YOU SOURCE OF SUPPORT THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
SEC THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
BOARD HAS HAD TROUBLES GETTING.
SMALL SYSTEMS WITH FOURTEEN OR
MORE TO DO PROPER OPERATIONS TO
DO PROPER INVESTMENT TO DO THE
PROPER CONSOLIDATION WHEN WE
HAVE JURISDICTION OVER THEM BUT
WE CAN ACTUALLY WE GAVE THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD
AUTHORITY TO FORCE CONSOLIDATION
WITH THIS FEELING WATER SYSTEMS.
ADMITTEDLY THAT MAY BE IN THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO HOW
ARE WE GOING TO GET THESE OTHER --
SMALL EVEN MY NEW SYSTEMS WHAT
TWELVE OR TEN HOOK UPS WE DON'T
HAVE ANY MUSCLE. TO FORCE THEM
TO DO ANYTHING OTHER THAN GIVE
THEM THE MONEY.
HOW WOULD THAT OCCUR SO WHEN THE
WATER BOARD IT LOOK FAT --
DIFFERENT WAYS TO SUPPORT OF
THESE SYSTEMS ONE OF THE FIRST --
METHODS OF SUPPORT IS LOOKING AT
WHETHER THEY ARE ALGO FOR
CONSOLIDATION OR EXTENSION OF
SERVICE SITES CAN WANT ONE OF
THE PRIMARY -- WAVE TO TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM OF THE WATER BOARD
CONSIDERS BEFORE THEY WOULD
CONSIDER OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE CORRECT BUT THAT'S
FOR I GET THAT I I I KNOW THAT
WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT.
THE SYSTEMS THAT HAVE FOURTEEN
HOOK UPS I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SEVEN OR EIGHT
HOOK UPS OR SOMEBODY WHO JUST AS
A WELL.
THAT ADMITTEDLY HAS POOR GROUND
WATER AND IS NOT POSSIBLE THEY
THE THEY FALL INTO THIS MILLION
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
WE DON'T HAVE AUTHORITY TO MAKE
THEM TO ANYTHING.
BUT IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THAT WERE
TAKING GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS IN
MAKING I'M OF BAILABLE TO THEM.
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
PLEASE REMEMBER THIRTY RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED TO THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT GIVES US A STORY
WE HAD UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
PROBLEM HERE AND IN [inaudible]
SO THAT'S A CHALLENGE.
A METAL ME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I BELIEVE THE BILL ALSO ONE OF
THE PURPOSES OF THE BILL IS FOR
THE WATER BOARD TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO THESE
COMMUNITIES TO SO THAT'S A GOOD
LIST OF EXAMPLE WHERE.
THERE MIGHT BE A SITUATION WHERE --
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF PROVIDING
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS
NEEDED FOR THOSE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS I MEAN THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY -- IT'S KIND OF
A OF A IT'S NOT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL THAT IT'S VERY ON THE EACH.
COMMUNITY MIGHT HAVE SOME UNIQUE
NEEDS AND THAT'S WHERE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE COMES IN
WHERE CONSOLIDATION MIGHT BE ONE
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
OF IN THEN WHEN -- THAT DOESN'T
WORK THEN THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE WATER BOARD
TO HELP THESE COMMUNITIES --
IDENTIFY WHAT THE PROPER
SOLUTION IS IN THAT PARTICULAR
SITUATION.
THE STATE HAS THAT ABILITY TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH
JUSTICE BE AN ED -- OBJECTION
FROM THESE LOCAL OPERATING
SYSTEMS TO DELIVER THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER THAT WE WE SEE WE
SEE THAT WE WE WANT.
AND THE LACK OF FUNDING SO THIS
PROVIDES THE FUNDING THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A POSSIBLE INCENTIVES
THAT WOULD MOVE THE NEEDLE.
AND THAT KEEPS ME TO THE NEXT IT
PROVIDES FUNDING BUT DOESN'T YOU
KNOW HI I'VE RAISE SOME
QUESTIONS BEFORE ABOUT THE NEXUS
BETWEEN AB THIRTY TWO THAT
REQUIRES REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE
GASES IN THE LANGUAGE.
THAT'S BEEN INCLUDED HERE TOO
YOU KNOW -- IN TO INSERT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ALL THAT YOU'LL SAID
KERR WITH CLIMATE CHANGE VERSUS
THE REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE
GASES.
I'M LOOKING AT PAGE SIX WORDS
YOU NEED TO FIND CLIMB IS
CLIMATE CHANGE CLIMATE CHANGE IS
EXASPERATING THE WATER IMPACTS
ON DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
REDUCING SURFACE FLOWS.
EXCEL RING DECLINING GROUNDWATER
BASINS AND ALL THESE.
SORT OF A CATCH ALL OF OF ALL
THE ILLS AT ME OF KERR IN THE
WATER ARENA -- BUT THAT DOESN'T.
HYPHEN THE NEXUS BETWEEN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES -- AND
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE LANGUAGE
THAT YOU PUT IN HERE IN AB. ONE
HUNDRED SORT OF KILLS ANY ANY
HOPE THAT WE HAVE THAT AB.
THIRTY TWO SURVIVED UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I'LL CONCEDE.
REGRETTABLY THAT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BASED ON A. B. THREE
NINETY EIGHT THAT OU'RE ABLE TO
USE OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS FUND
FOR VARIETY DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT -- CHARGES BUT NOW
WITH THIS LEGISLATION IT SEEMS
THAT YOU WERE EXPANDING THE TYPE
OF ACTIONS A GREENHOUSE GASES
CAN BE.
BE USED IMMEDIATELY IMMEDIATELY
BEGINNING.
ON THE ADOPTION OF THIS FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND A
CATCH ALL IS THERE ANYTHING IF
THIS PASSES THAT GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS COULD BE USED
FOR GIVEN THE DEFINITION THAT WE
HAVE COMPUTER.
CONTAINED IN THIS IS APPARENTLY
SAFE DRINKING WATER ACT THAT
EXPANDS THE FOR THE POLICY
THOUGH I A A JUST TO BE CLEAR I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU ARE
LOOKING AT THE JUNE TWENTY FIRST
VERSION OF THE BILL.
WHICH IS THE BILL THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEFORE BEFORE US.
PURSUE SWITCH TODAY.
WHAT WILL THE JUNE?
YOUR REFERENCE TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WAS A REFERENCE TO A
PRIOR VERSION OF THE BILL.
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
WHICH WAS AMENDED ON JUNE TWENTY
FIRST.
WHICH WAS ON FRIDAY -- HAS -- MY
HAS MORE NARAL LANGUAGE AND
THAT'S THE BILL THAT'S UNDER
CONSIDERATION NOW.
AND THE LANGUAGE OF THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
WOULD -- RESEARCH WOULD ALLOW OF
A WOULD BE SPECIFIC TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE SAFE AND
FOR AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FUND.
AND BASICALLY ONLY IN THAT
PARTICULAR APPROPRIATION OF
COULD THE WATER BOARD EITHER --
DEMONSTRATED RESULTS.
DEMONSTRATE A REDUCTION IN GHG
EMISSIONS OR DEMONSTRATE THAT IT
ADDRESSES CLIMATE ADAPTATION
RESILIENCY.
AFFECTS WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF A. B..
THREE NINETY EIGHT SO THAT'S THE
CURRENT VERSION WERE TALKING
ABOUT NOW WHICH IS A MORE
NARROWLY CRAFTED -- LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION.
THERE BY.
CENTER OFF.
THE MANAGER I I SEE THAT THE I
WAS GOING TO ASK IF WE CAN
EXPECT A FOLLOW UP REPORT ON
RESULTS.
WE HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL ATION PLAN
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE.
THE FUND IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
THAT'S DELIVERED TO THE
LEGISLATURE WILL INCLUDE SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT EXPENDITURES
FOR THE PRIOR YEAR.
DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT THIS FUND
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WILL
ACTUALLY.
OUTLINED A PLAN OF ACTION BEYOND
ONE YEAR AT A TIME AND HAVE A
TARGET DATE.
AT WHICH POINT WE EXPECT THESE.
SICK WATER SYSTEMS TO BE. TO BE
WELL.
ANOTHER WAS A GET WELL DAY.
I'M I'M TRYING TO FIND OUT IF
THERE'S SOME PROGRAM IS TO SOME
PLANNED.
PLAN OF ACTION HERE WE JUST
GOING.
TO SPEND MONEY IN.
SO AS PART OF THE REQUIREMENT OF
THE PLAN IS TAT THEY OF THE TO
ANNUALLY AND EVERY SINGLE YEAR --
IDENTIFY THE PRIOR YEAR'S
VENTURES AND EVERYTHING WILL
YEAR IDENTIFY THE PLANT LEVEL
EXPENDITURES HOWEVER AS PART OF
THAT THERE'S ALSO -- DATA
COMPONENT THAT NEED TO BE
INTEGRATED TO IDENTIFY WATER
THOUGH THERE'S SYSTEMS THAT ARE
EITHER ALREADY FEELING OR ARE AT
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF FAILING AND
THEN AS PART OF THE PLAN IS
IDENTIFYING THE SOLUTIONS TO THE
REMEDY.
THOSE ISSUES ONGOING RIGHT I
CERTAINLY WOULD EXPECT SOMEBODY
TO DO SOME THINKING HERE AND
FIGURE OUT THE WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE OF WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE SICK.
AND IT'S GOING TO COST US TWO
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN AT
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION A
YEAR IT WILL TAKE US.
NEXT NUMBER OF YEARS TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM.
IT'S ASSUMING IT'S FIXABLE.
AT SOME POINT TIME.
AND THEN WE CAN PLAN ON NOT
SPENDING A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR YOUR
ANYMORE RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
JUST GO BACK TO THE THE ONE THE
COMPONENT OF THE PLAN IS TO
IDENTIFY THE ANTICIPATED NEED
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
ARE FAILING OR AT RISK OF
FAILING -- AS SO THAT THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A
LONGER TERM LOOK -- TO SEE WHAT
THE WORLD IF YOU HAVE THE THREE
UNDER FAILING SYSTEMS CURRENTLY
IN PLACE WHAT IS THAT LEVEL THE
NEEDED AND THE END OF THE
FUNDING WOULD BE PRIORITIZE. TO
IDENTIFY WHAT WOULD BE THE
PROGRAMMATIC EXPENDITURES IN
THAT NEXT FISCAL YEAR BUT THERE
IS A MORE HOLISTIC COMPONENT OF
IDENTIFYING WHAT IS THAT GREATER
NEED.
WELL I DON'T SIT ON THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT IN THE
FUTURE THE MATTER COMES BEFORE
THE BIG BUDGET COMMITTEE I GUESS
YOU CAN ANTICIPATE THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU WILL.
GET FROM ME IN FUTURE YEARS.
WITH RESPECT TO THIS PROJECT.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU FOR
REMINDING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I SAID A COUPLE OF FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS. NINE TWO ONE EIGHT
NINE WHICH THE WORK OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND LEADERSHIP
IN ACHIEVING THIS.
MECHANISM TO REMEDY WHAT'S.
AN IMMEDIATE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IN AS MANY AS THREE
HUNDRED COMMUNITIES ARE WATER
DISTRICTS -- I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
QUESTIONS ABOUT NEXUS IN CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU IN
FRONT OF US TODAY HAVE KNOWLEDGE%
OF THE IMPACTS OF DROUGHT ON THE
WELL SYSTEMS THE BECOME STRESSED
IN LEACH MORE CONTAMINANTS AS A
RESULT OF DROUGHT IS THAT AN
ACCURATE STATEMENT.
YES AN ALTERNATE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE SERGIO TO SPEAK ABOUT
THAT.
YES SO ON THE THE CLIMATE CHANGE --
IT DOESN'T ADD RESULT IN ADVERSE
IMPACTS TO WATER AVAILABILITY
AND WATER QUALITY -- AND BOTH AS
A RESULT OF INCREASED -- IN
PROLONGED NESS OF DROUGHT BUT
AND ALSO ON THE OPPOSITE
SPECTRUM -- MORE HEAVIER
RAINFALL WHICH COULD ALSO RESULT
AND GREATER FLOODING AND SO WHEN
IT COMES TO TO DROUGHT WHEN
THERE'S A INCREASED TEMPERATURE
AND THERE'S LOWER PRECIPITATION
IT COULD RESULT IN AN LONGER
PERIODS OF DROUGHT -- WHICH
RESULTS AND LET'S WATER
AVAILABILITY AND A HIGHER
CONCENTRATION OF THE
CONTAMINANTS WITHIN THE CURRENT
WATER SOURCES AND AND MUCH OF IT
ALSO IS NATURALLY OCCURRING
CONTAMINANTS WHERE YOU JUST HAVE
LESS AMOUNT OF WATER TO DILUTE.
THE CONTAMINATED DURING THE
DROUGHT PERIODS AND ALTHOUGH
MANY COMMUNITIES WITH AND
SUBSEQUENTLY HAVE TO RELY ON
GROUND WATER SOURCES WHICH IN
MANY CASES ARE CONTAMINATED.
ON THE OPPOSITE SPECTRUM WITH
THE FLOODING -- AS WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS THE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS -- THE
TRAFFIC -- RAINFALL THAT HAPPENS
IT'S ARE AFRAID OF TIME -- THAT
FLOODING BRING THAN A LOT OF THE
CONTAMINATION FROM THE SURFACE
TO THE THAT DRINKING WATER AND
SO -- THAT IS THE RESULT OF OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CHANGING AND
TEMPERATURES AND CHANGING AND
PRECIPITATION AS A RESULT OF THE
TEMPERATURES.
THANK YOU AND THEN.
THE MEDIAN FOLLOW UP.
I THINK YOU ANSWERED THIS WITH
SENATOR ROTH'S QUESTION.
BUT IT.
THE BILL AS A FORCE IN THE
TRAILER BILL DOES PRIORITIZE BUT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THEN LOOKING AT PRIORITIZING
REMEDIES THAT ARE.
BOTH MOST OF FICTION IN LEAST
EXPENSIVE SO YOU MIGHT LOOK AT
CONSOLIDATION YOU MIGHT LOOK AT
A TREATMENT FACILITY -- YOU
MIGHT EVEN LOOK AT EMERGENCY
BOTTLED WATER TO CONTINUE TO GET
A SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER SET
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT YES.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MA'AM THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
NIELSEN.
DOES THIS SAID LEGISLATION IN
THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE AND I
HAVEN'T REVIEW REVIEW THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL DOES IT.
THE TALKS ABOUT RELATED TO
DOMESTIC WELLS AND SOME MONEY
MAY BE DIRECTED. TO HELPING WITH
THE MYSTICAL PROBLEMS IS THAT
CORRECT.
THE WELLS ARE IN AN ELIGIBLE --
I USE THAT TO SUPPORT -- THE
SMALLER SYSTEMS AND WELLSO
THERE THERE'S A A BROADER USE
NOW EVERYTHING WE HEAR THE WATER
BOARD WOULD WORK WITH IS --
OBLIGATED BY THE REVIEW TO
PRIORITIZE AND ADDRESS THE HIGH
YOUTH NED BUT THERE IS A KIND
OF A BROADER LEVEL OF WHAT'S A
AVAILABLE USE OF THE FUND.
DOES IT IN ANY WAY.
EMPOWER THE WATER BOARD TO
REGULATE CONTROL -- THESE
DOMESTIC WELLS IN OTHER WORDS
THE CAPACITY THE DOMESTIC WELL
THE THE THE POPPING LIMITS ON
THE HOURS.
OF RUNING THE DOMESTIC WELL ANY
ANY POWERS THAT ACCORDED TO THE
BOARD TO GIVE THEM GREATER
REGULATORY AUTHORITY OVER.
THE OPERATION.
BY THE INDIVIDUAL OWNER OF THAT
DOMESTIC WELL -- THE TRAILER BUT
THE THOUGHT CONTAINING
ADDITIONAL REGULATORY OKAY
RATHER.
WE NEED FOR THE QUESTIONS.
I THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
PUBLIC COMMENT AB.
ONE HUNDRED BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE QUEUED UP I'M GOING TO
ASK EVERYONE TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO ABOUT A MINUTE AND
FEEL FREE OF SOMEONE.
IN FRONT OF YOU OF MAJOR POINT
FEEL FREE TO SAY DITTO FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MITCHELL CINDY
TALK WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB -- ONE
HUNDRED JUST ONE QUICK COMMENT
WE THINK THAT THIS IS THIS BILL
IS THE RIGHT SOLUTION THERE IS
ANOTHER BILL COMING FROM THE
ASSEMBLY.
THAT HAS A LOT OF SIMILAR
LANGUAGE BUT SOME DIFFERENCES IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE PRIORITIES THAT
THIS BILL HAS THE PRIVATIZATION
FOR HELPING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
IT ALSO WOULD EXPAND THE SCOPE
TO OUTSIDE OF MAKING SURE
THEY'RE SAFE DRINKING WATER.
SO WE THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
BILL THE BILL BFORE YOU TODAY
WE ARE TONIGHT VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
MANY OF US HAVE HAD WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WE SUPPORT AB
ONE HUNDRED AS WELL AS A DURABLE
AND THOUGHTFUL PROCESS FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE AGREEMENT THAT
WAS REACHED -- BY THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE IN
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU VERY THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
DEREK OFTEN BAFFLING CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT THANK FOR MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS DON
GILBERT FOR SAN FRANCISCO P. UC
AND SUPPORT ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND AGREE THAT THIS BILL IS THE
RIGHT SOLUTION THANKS.
NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR J. SNACK
ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT.
WE ALL KNOW THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO HELP FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT AB
ONE HUNDRED IS A BILL THAT WOULD
DO THAT THANK THANK YOU.
LEARN AT THE CANTON EVERY SALLY
WATER DISTRICT IN YUBA WATER
AGENCY ENTHUSIASTICALLY
DETAILING THE COMMENTS OF OUR
QUINCY ANYWAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLYN JENSEN
WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GIL DEL HAND WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AFTER ABOUT
THREE YEARS OR PLUS WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE VERY PLEASED TO STAND
HERE TODAY AND SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
NOLAN AGENT ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN PISTACHIO GROWERS
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA DERRY'S INK
CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRY COMMUNITY
COMMISSION.
CALIFORNIA FRESH FOR HIS
DECISION CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION FAR WEST EQUIPMENT
DEALERS IN WESTERN PLAN HEALTH
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANTHONY
MOLINA ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT SANTA CLARITA VALLEY
WATER AGENCY MESA WATER DISTRICT.
AND THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE AND
VARIOUS OTHER AGRICULTURE
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ADAM ROBIN WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
BRIAN A JACK IN SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BATH A LOSS SO ON
BEHALF OF THE CUCAMONGA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
REVENUES ARE AS DIVERSE FOR THE
LZR VALLEY MISCIBLE WATER
DISTRICT AND THE MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AIR NEMO
REPRESENT EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT ALSO IN SUPPORT
AND WANT TO AND ALSO ONE EXTEND
OUR APPRECIATION THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE LEADERSHIP FOR THIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
MANAGER MEMBERS CAN -- DIJO GO
WITH THE GLOCK A GROUP ON THE AT
THE SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT AND THE
LONG BEACH WATER DEPARTMENT IN
SUPPORT.
DANNY BERKELEY CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION SUPPORT.
JUSTIN ALL FEEL LET ME HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
A JASON BRYANT WESTERN UNITED
DURING AND AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NANCY BAKER WITH THEIR NEED
ASSISTANCE FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT --
THERE IS -- A MOTION.
HAS BEEN MADE ALREADY SO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB ONE HUNDRED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL FIVE
AYE NIELSEN AYE FEELS IN ON A
BILL -- ALSO.
ALSO I HER DAUGHTER FOR TOTAL
AYE JONES JONES I LEYVA LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MONNING.
MONEY NINE MORE LOOK MORE LIKE
ALL HIGH MORALE.
MORRELL AYE PAN PAN ON A ROTH
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN.
STONE STONE I AMBER.
AMBER I LIKE BECAUSE HE WHY
BECAUSE HE NOW.
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THAT ITEM OPEN
ANA.
JUST UNTIL THE WILL CALL ROLL ON
THAT ITEM ONE MORE TIME BEFORE
WE ADJOURN COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM TWO ON THE
AGENDA.
AB ONE OH THREE HEALTH TRAILER
BILL NUMBER [inaudible]
TWO FINANCE.
THIS IS THE SECOND HEALTH ON THE
BUS TRAILER BILL WITH A COUPLE
OF KEY CONSIDERATIONS FIRST IS
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION --
THIS COMMISSION IS DESIGNED --
CONSISTS OF THIRTEEN MEMBERS AND
IS DESIGNED TO LOOK AT OPTIONS
FOR UNIFIED HEALTHCARE FINANCING
SYSTEM INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED
TO SINGLE PAYER OPTIONS.
THE COMMISSION A IS REQUIRED BY
THIS TRAILER BILL TO PRODUCE TWO
REPORTS THE FIRST BY JULY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY WHICH IS AN
ANALYSIS OF CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
AND OPTIONS FOR TRANSITION TO A
UNIFIED FINANCING SYSTEM AND
THEN THE SECOND REPORT WOULD BE
DUE ON FEBRUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THIS WOULD
INCLUDE KEY DESIGN
CONSIDERATIONS FOR TRANSITIONING
TO A UNIFIED FINANCING SYSTEM.
A COUPLE OF OTHER KEY ITEMS IN
THIS BILL FIRST IS THE EXPANSION
OF FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL COVERAGE
TO UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS
WOULD OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL.
THROUGH THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE
SECOND IS AN INCREASE FOR
SENIORS AS WELL AS BLIND AND
DISABLED -- FOR ME THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM GOING UP 2110038% OF THE
POVERTY LEVEL THERE COUPLE OF
HISTORICAL REASONS WHY THAT
WASN'T THE CASE BEFORE.
A THIRD IS THE EXTENSION -- FOR
MENTAL HEALTH POST PARTUM
BENEFITS FOR MOTHERS IN MEDI CAL
FROM A SIXTY DAY PERIOD TO A ONE
YEAR PERIOD.
AND FINALLY FOR THE CMS BE
COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES PROGRAMS
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
FUNDING THEY RIGHT NOW HAVE A
VERY HEALTHY RESERVE -- SO THEY
WOULD NOT RECEIVE THAT FUNDING
UNTIL THEY GO DOWN TO A TWO YEAR
RESERVE LEVELS AT WHICH POINT
THE EXISTING A SPLIT WOULD
CONTINUE IN TERMS OF FREE
DIRECTION.
SO THOSE ARE THE MAIN ITEMS AND
HAPPY TO TAKEN QUESTIONS
APPRECIATE THAT MEMBERS.
SENATOR MORE LOCK.
IT'S PENSION SWEEP FUNDED BY THE
MULTI.
I'M INSURANCE MANDATE SECRETARY
OF THIS IS FOR WHICH PROVISION.
JUST FOR THE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
EVENT.
SO THE WAY THE ADMINISTRATION
HAD BEEN THINKING ABOUT IT IS
THAT THE PENALTY REVENUE WOULD
BE USED FOR THE SUBSIDIES FOR
COVERED CALIFORNIA AND THAT WAS
ACTUALLY IN THE OTHER HEALTHCARE
OMNIBUS BILL -- BUT WE PASSED
ALREADY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT YOU'RE WELCOME SENATOR
DORADO [inaudible]
YES.
I SUPPORTIVE OF OF THE MAIL --
AND I THINK THAT THE BILL FAILS
TO ADDRESS SOME KEY ISSUES.
AT THE SAME TIME -- SOME OF US
AGREE AND TRULY BELIEVE THAT
HEALTH CARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT --
BUT I THINK WE MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE.
A BASIC FAIRNESS BY NOT
EXPANDING MEDICAL TO COVER ALL
ADULTS ESPECIALLY OUR SENIORS --
THIS BODY SUPPORTED AS BE --
TWENTY NINE TO PROVIDE COVERAGE
TO SENIORS THAT'S NOT INCLUDED
IN AB.
ONE OH THREE UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS OF LIVED AND WORKED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES BUT THEY
ARE LEFT BEHIND. FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
SENIORS ARE FORCED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK LATER IN LIFE AND YET
THEY'RE STILL CONTRIBUTING TO
OUR ECONOMY.
OF AND I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
UNDOCUMENTED PAY TAXES.
THEY PAID THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN IN STATE AND LOCAL TAXES AND
YET THEY'RE CUT OUT.
PREVENTED OF AND DOCTOR DOCTOR
VISITS.
SENIORS ON DOCUMENTS SENIORS
MAKE UP ONLY THIRTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS ONLY.
THIRTY THOUSAND IN CALIFORNIA --
IT'S A SHAME THAT WE COULDN'T
COVER THIS SMALL POPULATION.
THIS YEAR. THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
OUT OF THREE MILLION UNINSURED.
IN THE TOTAL IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR CONTINUES OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR THIS UNTIL WE COVER AND
TREAT ALL CALIFORNIANS THE SAME
WITHOUT ANY DISCRIMINATION --
OUR SENIORS CAN'T AFFORD MORE
DELAYS FOR UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
EVERY DAY -- EVERY DAY WE WAIT
MEANS MORE EXPENSE OF EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS ESPECIALLY AS
SENIORS -- AND SHORTER LIVES FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO DESERVE THEIR
DIGNITY IN THEIR OLD AGE OLDER
AGE [inaudible]
OF I SEE THAT THAT THE CREATION
FOR ME THE CREATION OF A TASK
FORCE OR THE RENAMING OF A TASK
FORCE.
IS WERE PUTTING OFF THIS ISSUE
AND WE'RE PUTTING IT OFF FOR
YEARS TO COME -- I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A A DAY TO BY JULY FIRST
OF NEXT YEAR BY WHICH A REPORT
IS EXPECTED.
BUT THAT'S AFTER THE BUDGET IS
APPROVED -- AND WHO KNOWS WHAT
WILL COMMENT INTO THAT REPORT.
SO THE WAY I SEE IT IS HERE'S A
COMMISSION THAT WE'VE ASKED TO
LOOK INTO THIS BUT THIS BODY HAS
APPROVED IT -- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND YOU KNOW
WHEREVER HOWEVER THE DECISION IS
MADE TO PUT IT OFF INTO A
COMMISSION WHICH IS KICKING IT
DOWN THE ROAD FOR SEVERAL MORE
YEARS.
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S A A
BUREAUCRATIC -- YOU KNOW TOOL TO
PUT THINGS OFF.
BUT TO PUT THIS OFF FOR SENIORS
WHO NEED THIS HEALTH CARE NOW IS
UNCONSCIONABLE -- I I JUST -- I
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
COULDN'T COVER FORTY THOUSAND
MORE INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE
THAT IS SO WEALTHY WE TALK ABOUT
HOW WEALTHY WE ARE HELP.
OUR ECONOMY IS THE FIFTH BEST IN
THE WORLD AND WE COULDN'T
INCLUDE FORTY THOUSAND SENIORS
WHO NEED THAT COVERAGE NOW.
WE TREAT ALL CALIFORNIANS THE
SAME WHEN IT COMES TO OTHER LIFE
AND DEATH THERE'S NO EXCLUSION
ONE FIRST RESPONDERS GO TO A
FIRE GO TO EMERGENCY THEY DON'T
SAY LET ME SEE YOUR DOCUMENTS
BEFORE I RESPOND BEFORE I TAKE
CARE OF YOU.
WE DON'T DO THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO CLEAN WATER.
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THAT.
AND I'M SURE THEN IN THOSE LOW
INCOME DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THERE ARE A LOT OF UNDOCUMENTED.
WE DON'T DO THAT WE DON'T
EXCLUDE THE MOST LABOR LAWS --
SAFETY ON THE JOB WE DON'T
EXCLUDE AND SAY SHOW ME YOUR
PAPERS BEFORE WILL.
AND FORCE THOSE LAWS AND THOSE
RULES AND WHY BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO EXCLUDE.
BASED ON WHETHER YOU DOCUMENTED
OR NOT WE LIVE TOGETHER WE GO TO
SCHOOL TOGETHER WE WORK TOGETHER
WE GO TO CHURCH TOGETHER OUR
KIDS GO TO SCHOOL IN THE SAME
SCHOOLS.
AND BECAUSE WHY BECAUSE WE ALL
BENEFIT FROM THE INCLUSION THEIR
INTEGRATED THEY'RE PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TO SEGREGATE
THEM OUT SOME WAY THINKING THAT
WE'RE BETTER OFF BY DOING THAT.
JUST MAKES ZERO ECONOMIC SENSE
SO I'M DEEPLY DISTURBED BY
PUTTING THE SOFT KICKING THE CAN
DOWN THE ROAD AND NOT THINKING
ABOUT THOSE SENIORS A WHAT THEY
NEED TODAY THEY'VE CONTRIBUTED
THAT CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE.
IT'S JUST ONE VERY VERY SMALL
PIECE.
IN THE NUMBER OF UNINSURED IN
THE STATE SO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE TO EXPRESS
MY DISBELIEF AN YOU KNOW ANGER
ANY MOTION AT THEM BEING
EXCLUDED -- THROUGH THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SELECT RESPOND.
HOW TO SAVE WE DEFINITELY HERE
HERE THAT CONCERNED -- WE SHARE
THE GOVERNOR'S EXPRESSED HIS
BELIEF THAT HE WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE TO A STAGE WHERE EVERY
PERSON IN THE STATE IS COVERED.
AND SO THIS TRAILER BILL DOES
SOME OF THAT IN MOVING FROM ASIA
NINETEEN TO TWENTY SIX BUT THERE
IS CERTAINLY A WAY TO GO TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL [inaudible]
THIRTY PAN.
I THANK YOU -- FIRST OF ALL I DO
ONE THING THE GOVERNOR FOR
MAKING STEPS WE ARE MAKING TODAY --
TO TRY TO WORK TOWARD -- THE
GOAL OF A UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE MUTUAL OF COVERAGE.
SO I WANTED KNOWLEDGE AND AND
APPRECIATE AND THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR THAT HE DID PUT
SOME MARKERS OUT THERE -- WE
HAVE A GROUP THAT'S GONNA STUDY
IT -- NOT AS FAR AS I THINK WE
WILL LIKE TO WE IN THE SENATE
DID PROPOSE -- SOME ADDITIONS --
THAT AND FOR NOT MAKE AN
AGREEMENT BUT I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE -- EX YOU KNOW EXPANDING TO
AGE TWENTY FIVE ALTHOUGH I THINK.
I WANTED ISSUES THAT WE'VE ALSO
SAID HERE IN THE SENATE IN
ADDITION TO THE SENIORS IS THAT
WE WANT PEOPLE FALLING OFF OF
COVERAGE SO WELL WE CERTAINLY
THE RATE YOU KNOW IN THIS WE'RE
GOING.
TO HIT AND WE DID THE KIDS
BEFORE AND WE HAD PEOPLE FALLING
OFF ON THE HIT EIGHTEEN NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE UP TO TWENTY
FIVE HOPEFULLY.
IN FUTURE BUDGETS WE CAN.
STAY AHEAD OF OF THAT -- AS WELL
AS HOPEFULLY WE EVERY VISIT --
WHAT WE PROPOSED ORIGINALLY --
THE SENIORS AS WELL -- BUT I
THINK IT ALSO COVERS SOME
IMPORTANT GAPS TO INCLUDING --
YEAH THE THE SENIORS THE SENIOR
GAP ANDS AND ALSO -- INCREASING
THE ELIGIBILITY FOR PREGNANT
WOMEN AS WELL SO -- I WOULD --
AND I APPRECIATE THAT -- WE HAD
SOME THE GOSHEN AROUND THE CMS
P. PROGRAM -- I UNDERSTAND
CERTAINLY IS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
SOMEONE AS A LARGE RESERVE BUT
ALSO WANTED THE ADDED TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT WE NEED. TO BE SURE
THOSE PROGRAMS -- DON'T ACTUALLY
FAIL IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE WE
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE GONNA DRAW
DOUBTS ARE RESERVISTS THAT.
THAT'S A POINT WE HAVE TO PICK
THEM UP AND YOU KNOW MAYBE MAYBE
THE WHOLE -- ISSUE AROUND WELL
THIS WAS LIKE YOU KNOW WE WANT
TO GIVE ME PEOPLE WE CAN ON OUR
VARIOUS COVERAGE PROGRAMS BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT UNFORTUNATELY DUE
TO THE PUBLIC CHARGE -- PEOPLE
MAY BE AFRAID SIGN UP WE NEED TO
GIVE THEM SOME ALTERNATIVES AS
WELL AND SOME OF THE SAME AS
YOUR ROGRAMS ARE ARE ARE ARE
TREATING THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL SO.
WE HAVE TO THINK THAT WE MAY
NEED MULTIPLICITY HAVE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES -- ACCESS POINTS FOR
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
CARE THEY NEED AND SO IT'S ONE
OF THE MARKER THERE ON THAT SO
THAT WE KNOW IN THE FUTURE OF
THAT ONCE WE USE THOSE RESERVES
WE DO NEED HELP SUPPORT THE
COUNTIES TO HAVE THESE PROGRAMS
TO BE SURE.
WE CONTINUE THIS PROGRAMS WHEN
ALL THIS PROGRAMS FAIL AND SAID
WELL WELL WE KNOW BACK THEN WE
DECIDED. TO DOWNTOWN SPEND
RESERVE SO WITH THAT I WOULD
CERTAINLY LIKE TO MOVE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP BEFORE WE
HEAR FROM SENATOR SKINNER -- AND
THEN FALL BY CENTER LEYVA QUICK
QUESTION I'M LOOKING AT THE
NEWLY MINTED LANGUAGE
INTERSECTION TO THAT DEFINES THE
APPOINTEES OF THE NEW COMMISSION.
AND I SEE REFERENCE TOOL
COMMITTEE -- OF POTENTIAL
ADVISORS BUT THE GOVERNOR GETS
EIGHT APPOINTMENTS I THINK THE
SENATE GETS TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE GETS -- TO AND I'M
HOPING THAT IN CONSIDERATION OF
THOSE APPOINTEES THAT -- IMPACT
THE COMMUNITIES WILL ALSO BE
CONSIDERED I HOPE THAT THAT THAT
ISN'T THE EXPECTATION OF THE
ADVISORY KIND OF ARM BUT THE
ACTUAL VOTING COMMISSIONERS.
ON THAT YOU WILL CONSIDER AMONG
THOSE A THE POINTY APPOINTEES --
IMPACT THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS
EITHER -- FOLKS WHO RUN CLINICS
BUT IMPACT TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT WILL CERTAINLY TAKE THAT JUST
MY LITTLE SUGGESTIONS THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER FOLLOWED BY
LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- JUST
FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR COMMENTS --
WE IF FOR ME ANYWAY OUT IT HAD
PREFERENCE FOR THERE TO BE A
LITTLE MORE BALANCE BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE APPOINTMENTS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS JUST --
TOM CLEARLY THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN
WORKING ON VARIOUS PROPOSALS TO
GET UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE FOR
SOME.
TIME NOW SOME OF WHICH BEEN
SUCCESSFUL SOME OF WHICH NOT --
FIVE BUT I REALIZE THE BILL IS
AS DESCRIBED NOW I HOPE THAT WE
WOULD LOOK IN THE FUTURE FOR
HELP PERHAPS SUGGESTING THOSE
APPOINTMENTS TO ADDRESS BOTH THE
CHEERS CONCERNS TO MAKE SURE
THAT IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
REPRESENTED BUT ALSO THERE MIGHT
BE MORE LEGISLATIVE BALANCE.
BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY BUT I WANTED ALSO
FOLLOW UP FOLLOW UP ON MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENT SENATOR DRAWS
WAS AROUND -- THIS ISSUE OF THE
THIRTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA WHO.
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE BILL AND
WHO THE SENATE WANTED TO HAVE
INCLUDED.
AND I THINK THAT IS WORTH IT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO DO
SOME.
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THE COST IS OF
THIS EXCLUSION WELL WE FULL WELL
KNOW WHAT THE COST IS OF
INCLUDING BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT
IT.
COSTS FOR MEDI CAL -- FOR OF
CERTAIN AGE.
I THINK THAT.
THE COST FOR THE EXCLUSION COULD
BE QUIZ TYPE NOT HIGHER.
PARTLY BECAUSE THESE FOLKS WILL
NOW BE DEPENDENT ON EMERGENCY
ROOM CARE THAT'LL BE THE ONLY
REAL CARE -- AVAILABLE TO THEM
BUT IN ADDITIONALLY THERE'S A
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS
ANYTIME WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
NOT COVERED.
IN DATE THEN.
DELAY BEING TREATED.
FOR ANY TYPE OF CONDITION.
THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S
COMMUNICABLE AND THERE COULD BE
ANY NUMBER OF THINGS THERE'S NO
VACCINATIONS FOR MURSI'S STAPH
INFECTIONS FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE ARE LOTS OF FOUR TWO WELL
THERE'S VACCINATIONS FOR
TUBERCULOSIS THERE IS -- THERE
IS NOT RIGHT IT'S LIMITED VERY.
YEAH THIRDS NOT -- AVAILABLE
IT'S LIMITED AND WE SEE WITHIN
OUR LOWER INCOME POPULATIONS AND
A RISE IN TUBERCULOSIS --
THERE'S LOTS OF CONDITIONS THAT.
WOULD THAT IN FACT THREATEN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OF THE REST OF US
BY ARE NOT COVERING HEALTHCARE
FOR EVERYONE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ALREADY HAVE.
NOT BY ACTIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT BUT BY ACTIONS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAVE SO MUCH FEAR IN OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY NOW WE'RE
TALKING FEAR IN MORE THAN JUST
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
AS I WAS DRIVING TO THE CAPITAL
TODAY.
I LISTEN TO REPORT ON A STUDY
DONE BY UC BERKELEY OF CHILDREN.
OF NOTED I ROOM IN CHILDREN
SHOULD SAY SONS AND DAUGHTERS SO
THESE ARE ADULTS.
OF THEIR US CITIZENS BUT THEY
ARE.
THEIR PARENT IS LIVING WITH THEM
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE A
PARENT THAT'S UNDOCUMENTED.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE OWN US CITIZENS
WHAT THE RIVER.
RESEARCH SHOWED THEIR STRESS
LEVELS THEIR ANXIETY LEVELS.
AFFECTING SLEEP AFFECTING MANY
ASPECTS OF THEIR HEALTH OUR WAY
UP BECAUSE OF THEIR FEAR FOR
THEIR FAMILY.
WE KNOW NOW THAT MANY OF OUR
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AGAIN THEY
MIGHT ONLY HAVE ONE PERSON IN
THEIR FAMILY WHOSE UNDOCUMENTED.
ARE NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF ANY
GOVERNMENT SERVICES FOR THE FEAR.
THAT -- THAT IS BEING THAT IS
BEEN PROVOKED NOW BY THESE
THREATS FOR IMMIGRATION ACTION.
YOU ARE EVEN LESS LIKELY TO GO
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM IF YOU
HAVE NO HEALTH CARE.
THEN YOU MIGHT BE WILLING TO USE
YOUR MEDI CAL BECAUSE AT LEAST
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZED YOU.
AND MADE YOU.
A A LEGAL USER SO YOU MAY HAVE
LESS FEAR ABOUT GOING AND
SEEKING OUT HEALTH CARE WHERE AS
NOW THERE MAY BE EVEN GREATER
BECAUSE EVEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS NOT IS BASICALLY
NOT RECOGNIZING YOU AND
PROVIDING YOU HEALTH CARE.
SO I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT TO
MENTION TO OUR CONVERSATION AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN REMEDY IT IN --
THIS UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR THANK
YOU SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL -- BUT I
WANT TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
SENATOR TO RAZA THOSE COMMENTS.
WE ALL WORK HERE AND WE SERVICE
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT ROUTE WE WE
REPRESENT BUT I KNOW WE ALL HAVE
PEOPLE WHO -- KIND OF ARE
SOUNDING BOARDS FOR ME ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE AS MY MOM.
AND YOU KNOW SHE'S A SEVENTY TWO
YEAR OLD WOMAN MY DAD'S A
SEVENTY TWO YEAR OLD MAN AND
THEY ARE BOTH.
ALMOST RETIRED THEY CHOOSE THE
WORK BECAUSE THEY WANT.
TO BUT THEY'RE JUST REGULAR
PEOPLE AND WHEN MY MOM SAID TO
ME TWO WEEKS AGO.
HONEY WHY WOULD THAT HELP IN Y.
WITH THOSE THE OLDER PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT THE MOST WHY WOULD THEY
BE EXCLUDED AND YOU KNOW SHE'S
THINKING OF HERSELF AND SHE'S
THINKING OF MY DAD.
AS I THINK WE JUST HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THESE ARE REAL
PEOPLE WITH REAL ISSUES.
AND I ALSO THINK ABOUT WHEN I
WAS WITH THE LABOR MOVEMENT AND
IN THE TWENTY YEARS THAT WE
BARGAINED CONTRACTS.
EVERY SINGLE TIME WITHOUT FAIL
THE CORPORATIONS WANTED TO
ELIMINATE RETIREE HEALTH CARE
EVERY SINGLE TIME AND WE HAD A
FIGHT SO HARD TO KEEP THAT IN
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
GIVEN US ALL A GOOD DAYS OF
THEIR LIFE. TO MAKE THE COMPANY
BETTER FOR CALIFORNIA BETTER SO
I JUST THINK THAT WE OWE THEM
SOMETHING AND I TO FEEL THAT
HEALTH CARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND
IT'S NOT A PRIVILEGE.
SO I DO HOPE THAT WE WILL LOOK
AT THIS A LITTLE MORE CLOSELY IT
IS IN A HUGE GROUP -- BUT THE
LONGER PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO CARE THE MORE EXPENSIVE IT IS
FOR ALL OF US THANK YO THANK
YOU.
MISTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM CHAIR
I'M GONNA.
THE VERY BRIEF IN MY COMMENTS
TALKING ABOUT ISSUES OF THE
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA COMMISSION.
NUMBER ONE MADAM CHAIR I DO
THINK THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTIONS.
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I THINK
THE BOTTOM LINE AND I KNOW THAT.
NOT ALL OF US AGREE THAT'S FINE
BUT I THINK CALIFORNIANS ONE A
SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
IN ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD IS BEING ABLE TO
IDENTIFY NUMBER ONE WHAT THOSE
COSTS WILL BE INTO THE
CHALLENGES.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERN BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT WERE TAKING A PRE
EXISTING FIVE MEMBER COMMISSION
IN TRANSITION INTO THE FOURTEEN
MEMBER COMMISSION WITH THAT PRE
EXISTING BUDGET AS WELL THAT
FIVE MILLION THOSE ORIGINALLY
THE BUDGET THINK LAST YEAR IS
THAT CORRECT.
OKAY SO I I THINK ON SOME OF THE
TIME LINE SO WE HAVE THE JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THEN THE
SECOND TIME I JULY FIRST TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT TOPIC -- THOSE ARE
TOUGH TO BE ABLE TO HIT.
IN SO A MAN CHAIR I THINK IT
WOULD BE -- AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IN THIS PROCESS OF GETTING -- A
REALISTIC IDEA OF WHAT REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DELIVERED VIA THIS BILL BUT TO
BE ABLE TO THINK THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE.
TO DEVELOP A PLAN THAT INCLUDES
ALL THE OPTIONS BY JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY IT'S GOING TO BE A
TOUGH HAUL -- SO I JUST WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT JUST HOW WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO DEVELOP A
REALISTIC TIME LINE TO BE ADDED
TO THE WORK THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO ENSURE THAT A SYSTEM IS
GONNA BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND ESPECIALLY FOR MOVING
TOWARDS A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM I
THINK WE OWE IT. TO ALL OF US IN
THE VOTERS IN THAT RESIDENTS THE
STATE TO BE TO DO IT RIGHT --
AND NOT NECESSARILY FAST BECAUSE
IT'S WHAT THEY WANT TEN
DISCONNECTED TO GET YOUR
FEEDBACK ON THIS IS FOR TAKING A
PRE ESTABLISHED COMMISSION
TRANSITION IT THANK YOU BY THE
WAY.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO BE ABLE TO START
A VALUE IN SINGLE PAYER I
SUPPORTED.
NO THAT SOME DON'T THAT'S FINE
BUT I JUST WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE
ON THAT TOUGH QUICKTIME MY I'LL
MAKE A COUPLE THREE POINTS IN AN
ATOM MAY ONE AWAY AND ALSO I
THINK FIRST -- GOVERNOR SHARES
THAT PRIORITY AND IT'S WHY YOU
WANT TO RECONSTITUTE THIS
COMMISSION IN THIS WAY.
AND MAKE SOME THE TRADE OFFS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY
HOPEFULLY A LITTLE BIT EASIER IN
THE FUTURE TO MAKE AS WE MOVE
TOWARD BEING ABLE TO COVER
EVERYBODY.
IN TERMS OF THE SPECIFIC TIME
LINES IT IS AN AMBITIOUS
TIMELINE BY THE GOVERNOR WILL
HAVE THAT YOU A POINT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES SECRETARY
REALLY SPEARHEADING THE
COMMISSION AND DRIVING IT
FORWARD.
WE HAVE THESE DEADLINES IN
STATUTES WE KNOW WE HAVE TO MEET
THEM AND THE WAY THAT THE
DEADLINES WERE STAGGERED OUT
THERE WAS A PURPOSE BEHIND IT
WHICH IS THAT THE FIRST DEADLINE --
I KNOW AND I KNOW THIS TAX THEY
SEEM LIKE THEY SOUND A LITTLE
BIT SIMILAR BUT THE FIRST IN
LINE IS REALLY FOR AN ANALYSIS
OF THE EXISTING SYSTEM.
AND AND DEVELOPING SOME OPTIONS
YES AND THEN THE SECOND DEADLINE --
THAT'S REALLY THE DESIGN
CONSIDERATIONS SO WHEN YOU'RE
IMAGINING WHAT THIS NEW SYSTEM
WILL LOOK LIKE AND SO BETWEEN
THOSE TWO DEADLINES ABOUT SIX OR
SEVEN OR EIGHT MONTHS SO WE
THINK WOULD THAT TIME LINE
ALTHOUGH IT IS AMBITIOUS WE WILL
BE ABLE TO DEVELOP SOME
IMPORTANT OPTIONS.
IN ANY OF THIS IS GOING TO GO
WITHOUT SAYING TO BE MY LAST
POINT MADAM CHAIR IS IF WE'RE IF
THE GOVERNOR SERIOUS ABOUT GOING
TOWARDS A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM.
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE ABLE LOOK
AT FOLKS WHO ARE SERIOUS ABOUT.
DOING A DEEP DIVE AND WILLING TO
GO TO GET US THERE -- AND THAT'S
WHERE I GET WORRIED ABOUT IS
THAT -- AT TIMES THIS IS BEEN
REALLY SCARY FOR FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO JUMP OFF INTO A AND
WE'RE GONNA NEED THE RIGHT
PEOPLE THE RIGHT SEATS AND I
HOPE THAT WE'RE GONNA GET THOSE.
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF IT -- AND
NOT JUST THROW UP SOME
ADDITIONAL UP SCHOOLS JUST BEING
CANDID ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE RATHER THAN JUST PUT A
WINDOW DRESSING OUT THERE ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT.
YEAH I THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR
TAKES THIS VERY SERIOUSLY IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT HE'S THOUGHT ABOUT
FOR A LONG TIME HE CAMPAIGNED ON
IT SO I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
IT'LL BE A KEY PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR TIME IF YOU WORK ON THIS
THANK.
YOU.
AS WE INVITE PUBLIC COMMENT
UNLIMITED EMOTION.
THANK YOU PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M FAIR MAKE THEY TING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY TO
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES WHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CMS P.
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
A WE DO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS THIS
HOUSE AND THE ASSEMBLY AND THEIR
WORK ON IT FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET THAT WOULD HAVE
HIT SEVERAL OF THE MEDIUM SIZE
COUNTIES AS WELL AS THE THIRTY
FIVE CM SB SMALL COUNTIES.
THE WHAT'S IN THIS BILL IS A
GREAT COMPROMISE AND WE'RE WE'RE
VERY THANKFUL FOR THAT WE ALSO I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT COUNTIES
ARE READY TO ENGAGE WITH THE
COMMISSION AND AS THIS PROJECT
MOVES FORWARD BECAUSE WE ARE
PROVIDERS AND WE DO -- HELP THE
SAFETY NET SO WE LOOK FOR TO BE
IN PART OF THAT EFFORT AND WE
LOOK FOR TO WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
FUTURE WITH THAT COMMISSION
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE
THE PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE.
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY WE WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
INCLUDING -- THE MODIFICATION TO
THE RIGHT CITY MECHANISM.
IN THE BILL -- AND ALSO THE
INCREASE.
IN THE A LEVEL 210038% OF
POVERTY SO THAT MORE INDIVIDUALS
QUALIFY FOR PACE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA WE AGREE WITH MANY OF
THE COMMENTS EXPRESSED TODAY AND
HAVE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF IT
EXPANDING MEDICAID TO ALL.
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS AND AS SUCH
WE SUPPORT AT THE PROVISION TO
EXPAND AS A STEP AT TO YOUNG
ADULTS WITHIN THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE APPRECIATE
RAISING THE MEDI CAL AGING
DISABLED INCOME LIMIT.
ENDING THE SENIOR PENALTY THAT
SO THAT SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE NO LONGER
SUBJECT TO A LOWER INCOME
ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLD.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE A THE FIRST
STEP -- TO INCREASE OUR EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY TO UNDOCUMENTED
YOUNG ADULTS OF RECOGNIZING THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP THANK YOU
THANK YOU FINAL WITNESS RUN
CALLING ON BEHALFOF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE COMPROMISE THAT
WAS PUT INTO PLACE ON C. N. AS
P..
WE ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE YOU MUST BE HAS STARTED
TO ENGAGE IN WORK WITH ITS
PATHWAY TO HEALTH PROGRAM AND IT
WILL POTENTIALLY BE ABLE TO
EXPAND WHICH DOES OFFER SERVICES
TO A DOCUMENT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE OTHER OPTIONS.
WE ALSO SUPPORT RAISING THE
INCOME LEVEL -- FOR DE AGED AND
DISABLEDPROGRAM AND MEDI CAL TO
GO UP. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
NO LONGER HAVE A SHARE OF COSTS
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF TAKING A FIRST STEP
TO COVER.
THE UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS IN
MEDI CAL PROGRAM FROM AGES
NINETEEN TO TWENTY FIVE WE DO
SHARE SENATOR OUT OF THOSE --
THOUGHTS AND SENTIMENTS ABOUT
HOW WE GET TO ALL WITH THE
REMAINDER OF THE POPULATION
CERTAINTIES SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL HAS RAISED THIS
QUESTION ABOUT HOW WE ARE DOING
THESE INCREMENTAL STEPS
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE NEED WE
KNOW ON THE GROUND -- FOR
SENIORS WE ABSOLUTELY THANK THE
SENATE FOR THE WORK THAT THEY
DID DO TO TRY TO PRIORITIZE THEM
AS AN ISSUE IT WAS JUST THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND WE DO HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION.
MORE SOONER RATHER THAN LATER
AND POTENTIALLY WITHOUT.
DOING ANY ADDITIONAL WORK SINCE
pABSOLUTELY NEED TODAY TO MOVE
THAT ISSUE FORWARD -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THESE ISSUES AND AND GETTING TO
ALL PARTICULARLY ON THE
UNDOCUMENTED AND LOOK FORTY
IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MADAM
SECRETARY WILL CALLED.
THIRD DEPENDS NAME FIRST PLEASE
AND THE WILL CALL THE ROLL IF
YOU WANT TO THROUGH THE MOTION
IS TO PASS PAN.
PAN HI.
SENATOR MITCHELL BY MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN.
WILSON NO WELL -- ALSO.
DRAWS ALL I HER DAUGHTER HER
TOTAL AYE JONES.
JONES NO LEYVA LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE MONNING MONEY I'M
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE NO MORALE.
MORRELL NO.
ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE STONE NO NUMBER.
NUMBER NINE WHAT KASKI BECAUSE
THE AYE -- OVER THERE ON THE
FIRST OF FOR YOU -- WITH A VOTE
OF TWELVE TO FIVE THAT MOTION
CARRIES PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR OGDEN DIED AND ONE
EIGHTY ONE HUNDRED IF THE ONE
HUNDRED FELL.
STERN STERN I SIXTEEN ONE THAT
MEASURE KERRY'S.
BUDGET COMMITTEE STANDS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU